Kamath look guys my name is achernar and
welcome to my game engine series feels
so good to say that this series has been
in the making for like two years I'm a
finally beginning and today suitably I
think we're going to be talking about
what a game engine actually is because
before we start making one it's probably
a good idea to actually define what
we're going to be making and over the
next kind of few videos we are gonna
start planning this game engine
specifically so definitely check out
those later videos they will come out
very soon but first of all before I
begin I just want to say a huge thank
you to all the patrons who made this
series happen patreon accomplish the
Cherno is my patreon if you guys want to
support me then that would be absolutely
amazing because that is what makes this
possible and your continued support is
very very important to me so huge thank
you to everyone because I wouldn't be
here without you so it's just so amazing
that I can do this because I've wanted
to do this for so long and you've given
me the opportunity and the time to
actually do this ok so anyway in this
first kind of set of planning videos as
I want to say we're gonna be basically
just talking about what a game engine
actually is so game engines right
they've been around for a while
what are they why do we need them do we
even need them and what is it that we're
actually going to be making in this
series so people have very very broad
definitions of game engines ranging from
everything from like oh it's just
something that helps you kind of build
games quickly to like full kind of like
sweet of like tools that content
creators can use to make models and
everything like that
and I mean if you kind of just go on the
internet and search for a minute like
what a game it actually is and what
examples
you'll probably stumble upon engines
such as unity or unreal right and those
engines are examples of game engines
that have been kind of commercialized
and kind of I guess released out into
the public either for free or kind of on
subscription plans or on kind of some
kind of royalty agreement right and they
kind of present themselves essentially
as a set of tools like a one big tool
usually like a level editor pretty much
in which you can actually build your
game it's like a kind of platform pretty
much for building an interactive kind of
application doesn't even have to
necessarily be a game it's just really
at its core an interactive application
now those are the ones that you kind of
see that are out in the wild right
because they've been kind of
commercialized and publicized I guess as
specifically as game engines that is the
product the product is the game engine
but for a lot of companies it's not even
about you know making a game engine
that's not their product their product
is a game and so we look at all of these
video game companies like EA Ubisoft you
know whatever Activision Blizzard valve
they have their own in-house engines
that they've built that never see the
light of day as an actual game engine
they're not released as a game and no
one has access to them outside of the
company as a game and they're all
internal right but what they do provide
is a platform for the staff working on
those game teams to actually construct
that game to actually build that game so
when we think about a game engine what I
really want to kind of push for is the
idea of it's a platform which you can
use to build video games and the term
game again is something that I keep
coming back to because hypothetical you
know realistically speaking it doesn't
have to be a game now these game studios
their products are games so they do
build games with these engines but if
you look at something like unreal or
unity they can be used for much more
than just games they can be used for
building VR applications like
architectural visualizations even in
some cases simulations which again
obviously would require a lot of
additional code but they could just be
used
as a way to kind of build an application
kind of rendering lifecycle type type of
real-time application thing right
essentially what I'm saying is if you
want an application that displays
graphics in real time
you could just use unity or unreal to
visualize whatever data you have right
now on top of that it's not just even
about visualization it's also about
interaction on a number of platforms
even VR right it's a whole kind of
platform for you to actually kind of
convert the data that you have into a
more interactive will kind of oh I guess
interactive visual format and that's
where my definition of game engines come
comes in and I want you to just think
about for a minute what it is we're
building and what a game engine actually
is that's cool right let's simplify this
whole thing let's take it down a notch
and actually think about well okay good
it's a platform to build games but what
is it really it comes down to this and
before I continue coffee what would we
be without coffee anyway where are the
damages yes so what is a game engine at
school well basically what it is is a or
at least its goal is to transform data
from one format into another that's what
this is all about data transformation
right
we essentially read in a set of files
from disk we take the data from those
files and we transform it into something
else that shows up on our screens okay
that's it and furthermore we almost
always provide a way to interact with
that data as well but that's really all
a game engine is and that's what we're
going to be building something that
reads data in and transforms it into
something that we see on our screens now
because of the way I phrased that it's
important to realize that at its core
that's really what a game engine is it's
not a hard-coded kind of program
application that just does certain
things right if you're building that
you're probably most likely actually
just building an application or a
framework for an application like that
what we're building is something that
reads files in transforms them and then
puts them on the screen and as you know
interactive capabilities to that as well
that's what we're building and that's
really as simple as it is so because of
that it's important to realize the game
engines are extremely data oriented
meaning that the purpose of a game
engine is not to kind of create data
based on nothing right we're not doing
that at any point act like ever right
what we're doing is we're just loading
existing files now let's focus on the
files for a second where are these files
coming from what are they how do we make
them that is also part of what a game
engine is it's a platform to make those
files now we call these files assets an
asset is just something a file that the
game engine actually takes in as input
now I did say a file it doesn't have to
be a physical file but essentially it's
just a bunch of data it could be a
virtual file it could be something that
the game engine creates while running
right that is based on some other asset
like an asset it could tell the game
mentioned to create another asset for
example on the fly that would also be an
asset even those on a physical file but
what I'm saying is a game engine
typically includes a platform a suite of
tools that can create these assets right
it creates a way for us to actually
offer a sets now what I mean by that is
picture someone building a level for a
game or maybe building a 3d model or
texture or something like that
an artist or a content creator will
actually go in in a game studio
structure a content creator will use
game engine tools right to actually
author those assets now they might make
a texture in Photoshop or they might
make it make a 3d model in like 3d
studio max or Maya or something like
that right all blender
oh right but at the end of the day they
still need to get that model that's
pretty model into a format that the game
engine can actually receive because for
like kind of real serious kind of big
game engines it's pretty much never
happens that they just take in like you
know JPEG or PNG images or like just
kind of obj models or something like
that that doesn't happen right usually
they get built into a format that's
custom designed for that specific game
engine whether it be textures models
levels whatever so typically speaking
that content creator would also be
responsible for kind of you know turning
that kind of model in that third-party
format into the game engine format and
that's kind of defining everything that
needs to exist for that game and to
actually do something with that model
right because typically speaking game
engines probably have more than just the
data that is included in a model that's
exported from like Maya they might have
additional information such as where to
place it in the world what kind of other
components it might have on it what
functionality might have on it right all
that kind of stuff so that is
essentially what a contact writer does
creates content for the game engine so
in other words
content creators are responsible for
authoring assets for the game engine and
the game engine reads those assets at
runtime and essentially presents
something on the screen and presents a
way for the user to interact with that
and that is what a game is ok so we can
break down all the systems of a game
engine there are very very very many
systems of a game engine it depends on
the engine obviously but I'm not even
I'm thinking that maybe probably
wouldn't even be wise to kind of cover
that now we might just do that in the
next episode because in the next episode
we're gonna kind of go through all the
different systems of a game engine and
talk about how we're going to design and
actually implement them but essentially
in order to facilitate this kind of data
transformation that we have we need a
number of various systems right
including like platform abstraction
layers if we want out our engine all
this data transformation to happen on a
variety of platforms whether that be you
know desktop based platforms like
Windows Mac Linux or like mobile
platforms like Android Iowa
some console platforms like Xbox
Playstation you know Nintendo whatever
right we need platform abstraction
layers so that our code can kind of run
on different platforms and the point of
a platform structure layer of course is
to taste abstract those platforms
specific the platform details away from
us so the we can just write code that is
generalized for all platforms and then
there's many other I'm not even going to
get into everything that yeah men didn't
have you know we have rendering we have
kind of audio we have like filing put
out the way of serialization we have
just so many different things right that
facilitate is kind of dodge
transformation and again writing them is
going to be quite an adventure so I'm
really excited for this entire series
but apart from that kind of runtime
which takes that data transforms it and
puts up on the screen as I said and as
interaction to it apart from that you
know we also have the actual tools that
people use to both of that data
initially like a level editor for
example is probably I think the the
simplest example that most of you have
probably heard about or are used to you
know stuff like that that's also part of
a game engine because without that I
mean you're probably going to be stuck
actually writing out your levels
manually and like simple source code or
something like that which obviously
isn't going to be very very useful for
anyone so game engines a really huge
kind of topic they're these amazing kind
of engines really that take data
transform them but also provide a way to
actually author that data and that's
what this series is gonna be about this
is the first episode first official
episode of the game engine series in
which we're going to I'm going to along
with you guys it's going to be a lot of
community interaction a lot of community
support as well we're gonna go ahead and
we're gonna build a game engine from
scratch in C++ and in any in any other
languages that we decide we need to use
as well like c-sharp for example it's a
common one and this journey is going to
take a really long time it's gonna be
really in-depth I'm gonna treat this as
a tutorial series not like as I kind of
watch me write a game engine with
minimal explanation I'm actually going
to teach this as a course pretty much
and we're just gonna build this huge
system right and one of the reasons the
Gammage is exist as well remember is
that games nowadays have become so
complicated that if we were to do not
have that platform to build games upon
we would end up building everything from
scratch every time think about a team of
200 people making a game like I don't
know Grand Theft Auto or something like
that right just example to talk my head
that's probably way more than 200 people
probably like a thousands but anyway
right picture them trying to reiterate
can I kind of build the same technology
over and over again like that's
impossible
and furthermore engineers like
programmers right can't be available for
everything that is needed to make a game
like that right which is why engineers
end up building all these tools that
content creators are artists that aren't
familiar with programming or engineering
can actually use to build all the
content because as I just mentioned game
engines convert they they transform that
data
there's assets into something that you
see on the screen what are those assets
come from right content creators so
really when you think about it what is a
game well is a game about programming is
a game about writing code and doing all
that well not really write big scale
professional games aren't about that at
all they're about taking data and
putting it on the screen so that's
really all the game engine is doing and
that's kind of the point of it the point
of it is to say okay enough programming
enough writing code to do everything
right all we're going to do is design
some kind of way for people who aren't
familiar with programming to actually
create all that data to author elect art
of course they will need to be stuff
like scripting but don't direct
programming right that's kind of the
idea of a game engine and of course I am
being kind of general in that case there
is a lot of actual engineering support
required for games but in the ideal case
look at something like unity you can
make pretty much any kind of non huge
scale game with very minimal scripting
right because the bulk of the work is
just creating systems
can take that data and put and position
them on the screen at the right time and
also kind of cure of different events
that might happen and also add that kind
of interaction with the user anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did you can hit that like button you can
help support this series I got a patron
icon for slash the channel you'll get
many rewards such as access to source
code early access to videos about a week
early as well so all these videos will
be up a week early so if you want to
watch the second video it's actually
already up on patreon so you can just
watch that right now but also we have
like monthly hangouts on on discord and
there's private discord channels and
there's just so many rewards that you
guys get for helping support this series
because it's really important to me that
we kind of build this as a community and
your support is very important to me I
hope you guys enjoy this video I can't
wait to see in the next one next time
we're going to talk about all the
systems that we're going to kind of put
into our game engine and then after we
kind of get over that initial planning
and design stage which I do want to keep
very brief because we'll kind of you
know what I'm going to sign the whole
thing and then I may then start
programming what kind of kind of design
as we go but we still have to kind of
define the scope of this so that we can
start in the right place and not end up
rewriting quite a billion times so next
time we're gonna complain everything in
and up to that when I finally create
that new project from scratch and get on
with this at all I'll cover kind of
setting up the environment that you need
for this and all that stuff as well so
don't worry it's gonna be kind of step
by step from scratch every episode I
can't wait
I'll see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]